[Musik]
ich glaub ich hab dich wenn mir jemand
sagen würde haye luca du darfst in einem
kompletten leben nur noch videos von
einem youtuber schauen dann würde ich
natürlich meine lieblings youtube darin
katja krasser witz nehmen da fragt man
sich jetzt vielleicht herr luca warum
denn gerade katja dass es einfach weil
sie eine natürliche person ist
allerdings soll das heutige video nicht
davon handeln welchen youtuber ich denn
mein leben lang nur noch schauen möchte
sondern es geht darum dass katja einen
neuen zaun rausgebracht hat dicke lippen
ich habe auch dicke lippen oder an alle
unter euch die jetzt vielleicht nicht so
häufig auf youtube unterwegs sind das
ist nicht der erste song von katja casa
wird sondern schon jetzt weiter auf den
ersten song habe ich ja auch bereits
reagiert ich bin stimmen da kommt mir
jetzt schon wieder die drin das ist
kunst
das war mehr als nur kunst lobby gegen
wirklich einigermaßen klar freunde das
muss man wirklich zu geben also
natürlich der songtexte ein bisschen
jugendfreundlicher sein können aber naja
ich will allerdings gar nicht mehr an
drum herum reden meine lieben freunde
wir gehen mal direkt auf die wiedergabe
seite von den sorgen und zwar sehen wir
direkt ein mix von titania streifen
intakt streifen oder was hat jack raser
wird dicke lippen fish im musikvideo das
video wurde hochgeladen vor zwei tagen
bereits es tut mir leid ich habe es noch
nicht geschafft vorher darauf zu
reagieren
das sieht er den 48 stunde mehr als drei
millionen aufrufe erzielt das hat mehr
likes als discs das ist krass bei
youtuber songs die schauen uns jetzt
erstmal ganz kurz die tags an hat ja
krawitz dicke lippen musikvideo
offiziell auf fische die gehen ja alle
noch klar und dann kommt ich habe dicke
lippen und sie blasen
na gut aber mal schauen was so in den
kommentaren gesagt wird dick gelitten
ist ja noch schlimmer als lobby alter
die hunde tun mir leid
ok wann kommt die altersbeschränkung
muss es immer um sex gehen hast du keine
hobbys zu guten tochter ich habe so
einen müll produzieren alter welcher
idiot kauft sich diesen song schlimmer
als tobias der dicke fresse du warum
machst du diese videos dass ich
besteuert coole kommentare doch nun bei
der damen und herren sind wir an dem
moment angelangt deshalb ihr
wahrscheinlich dieses video mehr
eingeschaltet habe natürlich mache ich
bei solchen reaction sondern so dass mit
ich mir zuerst die tracks angucke den
titel die kommentare aber jetzt kommt
das musikvideo also wie gesagt hat ja
keiner mit previews bei start over click
mal drauf der blickfang an
ich hab das copyright du hast das
copyright auf den docks teil
da dürfte youporn jetzt aber ganz schön
viel gelder nicht abtreten müssen
ich kann also man merkt direkt in den
ersten 17 sekunden dieses dass der track
ist übrigens nur drei minuten das ist
relativ wenig für musik video man merkt
in den ersten sekunden direkt dass sie
bezug nimmt auf ihren bisher schon
hochgeladenen song body hier noch mal
ein ganz kurzer ausschnitt
mach es mit hingabe ich kann wie der
wind blasen fange ich an
was laberst du ich mache es mit hingabe
ich kann wie der wind blasen
was soll ich dazu noch sagen was ich
wirklich notwendig an dem musikvideo was
ich an den ersten sekunden bisher
festgestellt habe ist das sehr sehr
knallige farben sind also man sieht hier
direkt da so ein krasser hintergrund
hier dieses blauen dann dem orange
kontrast zur hautfarbe hier finde ich
fange ich an mit meinem mund haut es
sich um den kind haken
[Musik]
also sie berichtet mal wieder über
themen die nicht jugendfrei sind
dass es nicht heute
ich dachte dass ein text wirklich nicht
noch mehr +18 sein kann als bei doggy
übrigens schön wie du da gerade aussieht
katja allerdings schafft es katja
wirklich bei ihrem neuen song dicke
lippen innerhalb der ersten 30 sekunden
was die versorger des textes angeht
komplett zu überbieten
da kann man mal klatschen habe ich bei
man ein leichtes spiel wenn ich sage ich
will gern
nicht das eis am stiel
hat katja neuerdings tattoos ich glaube
das ist gar nicht katja aber meine damen
und herren klicken einfach direkt weiter
auf play weil gleich kommt der refrain
[Musik]
ich habe dicke lippen
ich hab dicke lippe
[Musik]
jetzt machten die texte auch sind
natürlich okay nach dem video schauen
wir uns gar nicht einmal den songtext
genauer an aber der refrain ist noch
dünner als bei dog eat dog ii war es ja
so in etwa hey gibt es mit jockey für
die liebste du weißt genau ich heute
schwach wenn es mir von hinten machte
dagegen zu dick sind und hier ist
einfach nur ich habe dicke lippen dicke
lippen dicke lippen und sie blasen also
katja bei dem nächsten track singst du
nur noch penis dann oder was mich
erinnern dass sehr sehr krass an die
atzen keine bange ich bin gut ist gut
ich weiß nicht warum aber das erinnert
mich sehr sehr stark an dicke lippen
[Musik]
also natürlich der text ist anders und
die komplette melodie ist anders und
alles möglich ist anders allerdings ein
bisschen vom stil her glaube ich will
sie mit ihrer musik so in die richtung
hudson strobo pop hey das geht ab und so
was alles gehen finde ich ehrlich gesagt
nein
katja ich habe bei gorki bereits
ausschauen gesagt dass ich es nicht so
schlimm finde wie du gesungen hat und wo
die entwicklung hingeht und so und das
finde ich ehrlich gesagt sehr mutig
allerdings auch schulungen nur dass der
text ist bis sind daneben und die
freizügigkeit aber an also wir schauen
mal weiter damals war das anders keinen
markenjeans kosteten ein körper so sie
wie du in drei jahren verdienst ist das
ein bitcoin logo also ihr körper kostet
so viel wie der zuschauer in drei jahren
verdient das heißt das
durchschnittsgehalt eines deutschen sind
glaube ich so 2500 euro monatlich das
heißt drei jahre
katjas körper kostet 90.000 euro also
wenn man mir sagen würde haye dürftig
mal deinen körper haben für einen tag
und alles damit machen würde ich nicht
sagen 90.000 euro
[Musik]
was fü feuerwehr ganze saison geht nur
ums blasen auch meister am rand macht
einen 24 stunden live stream wo er sich
nur katja das lied anhört so wenig
hobbys muss man erst mal haben nichts zu
sehen denn es war nicht so gemeint du
hast schon wieder ans eine gedacht ja
ich habe sie als eine gedacht und zwar
an dass hier das kann man auch gut
blasen
die lupe
[Musik]
was will ich jetzt abschließend zu dem
song sagen meine damen und herren also
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen wenn wir
noch mal so ein bisschen durch scrollen
wir sehen das logo und so finde ich mega
geil es ist ein bisschen reeperbahn fiel
er mit dem ganzen backstein und diesen
komischen neon led ist hier und was ich
wirklich sehr cool findet und diese
verschiedenen ganzen krassen farben also
dass ihre lippen hier einfach mal blau
sind dann liegen hier die ganzen scheine
dann ist es hier wieder hellblau dann
haben wir hinten glaube ich irgendwann
genau hier sind hier war es ein bisschen
lila hier fordern wir dann orange und po
hier am start richtig krasse farben
alles übel sättigung reich und das ist
das hat sie gut gemacht der rest muss
ich sagen text nicht jugendfrei alles
andere eigentlich auch nicht wirklich
jugendfrei was gezeigt wird apropos tags
wir wollten uns dann nochmal anschauen
wenn paar sekunden später das hier ist
so circa der komplette text also das
intro mit dicke lippen die klippen dann
hier die strophe dann der röhre
ich habe den geliebten dicke lippen die
blasen dann wieder der refrain dann der
post referrer also das hier ist
eigentlich alles komplett gleich das
hier ist das einzige wo sie sich wohl
irgendwie gedanken bei gemacht hat dann
können wir morgen weitergehen und stufe
zwei okay auch noch und dann der rest
hier also bei manchen liedern ist es ja
so bei so repp sachen da hast du gar
nicht mal richtig irgendwie einen
refrain und so ich habe auch wirklich
nicht so die todes ahnung von musik und
wie die ganze technik dahinter
funktioniert und so weiter und so fort
allerdings ist es bei vielen anderen
liedern halt der fall dass da enorme
meisterwerke sind und hier ist dann so
was wie hier die ganze zeit das gleiche
dann haben wir hier die ganze zeit das
gleiche und das ist auch das gleiche wie
ich hier ein paar dinge verstehe ich
nicht so ganz aber alles in allem muss
ich wirklich ganz ehrlich wiederzugeben
ich kenne ich ja nicht persönlich ich
habe noch nie mit ihr geredet
noch nie mit den kontakt gehabt ich
feiern konnte nicht aber wo sie mit der
musik angeht finde ich nicht so verkehrt
also ich denke dass sowas echt gut im
club funktioniert ich weiß noch nicht
bei einem live show von bei einer live
show von ihr oder ob ich denke dass das
dort echt potenzial hat bekommst von mir
ein abo unten daumen hoch und das
solltet ihr bei dem video hier auch mal
da lassen denn an dieser stelle wird das
heutige video auch beenden meine damen
und herren wenn es euch gefallen hat wie
gesagt das gerne mal einen like dann
schaffen wir 50.000 likes freunde
es ist eine krasse summe aber das wäre
echt todesfahrt jetzt noch zwei ganz
kurze sachen freunde und zwar erstens m
folgte ihm eigentlich schon auf
instagram denn dort habe ich heute ein
neues foto hochgeladen
instagram und freunde wenn ihr euch
dieses video jetzt wirklich bis zum ende
angeschaut habt dann geht mein neuestes
instagram bild und kommentiert diese
palme
dann sehe ich dass ihr auf jeden fall
dieses video hier bis zum ende
angeschaut habt und die zweite sache die
ich ganz gut fragen wollte freuen und
zwar ist das hier ein design was
eventuell am ersten sechs neu kommt in
den punkten also sieht das ganze hier
aus das ist die erschaffung adams und
wir haben da einfach ein paar pips
drüber gemacht und die smileys und vorne
springen noch alpakas raus wir haben das
gleiche auch noch gemacht mit dem
letzten abendmahl da haben wir auch
smileys drüber gepackt weil ich die idee
eigentlich ganz cool fand das ist jetzt
beispielsweise im bild von michelangelo
da einfachen 2d drüber zu packen das
ganze ein bisschen cool darzustellen ich
hatte überlegt dass am ersten sechs in
den shop zu hauen und freunde
ich wollte euch jetzt mal einfach ganz
kurz fragen weil es ja eventuell leute
gibt ich weiß wir leben im jahr 2018 und
das ist alles relativ locker
mittlerweile alles was heißt ich habe
eigentlich keine großartigen bedenken
bei so etwas zu produzieren herzustellen
zu bedrucken auf t shirts allerdings
wenn ihr jetzt wirklich sagen würdet hey
das ist echt nicht so cool dass du jetzt
so was nimmst so biblische dinge und das
auf deinen merchandise drucks mit einem
smiley drauf dann will ich das ganz sein
lassen
ich dachte nur bevor ich das jetzt
einfach am ersten sechs und zwei monaten
in den shop hoh auf das t-shirt hier
dass ich euch lieber mal ganz kurz frage
also wenn ihr sagt ja das ist überhaupt
kein problem wir leben im jahr 2018 und
ich mein ich bin selber gläubig also ich
will jetzt nicht irgendwie nen in seinem
glauben hier angehen dann findet ihr
hier
jetzt eine abstimmung eingeblendet also
sind findet ihr das ok das design oder
sagte das geht zu weit also stimmt gerne
mal oben ab eure meinung interessiert
mich da ich möchte da nämlich laden das
dann keinen schutzraum kommt oder leute
sich dahingehend beleidigt fühlen aber
jetzt freuen ich habe viel zu lange drum
herum geredet jetzt ist das video vorbei
und jetzt kommt das auto hier können
jetzt hier mal den kanal passieren oder
hier unten meinem shop ausschenken
hier findet ihr zwei andere videos und
wenn ich schon abonnent sein könnt ihr
auch die glocke klicken dann willkommen
die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]